A partir de ces conversations, j'ai fini par écrire un livre
et ce livre tournait vraiment autour de trois surprises -
enfin, pour moi, en tout cas.
J'ai déjà parlé de la première :
le cannabis possède vraiment des vertus thérapeutiques.
Ces vertus ne sont peut-être pas aussi énormes ou incroyables
que ce que certains de ses partisans les plus acharnés
veulent nous faire croire
mais elles existent.
Deuxième surprise :
le cannabis médicinal comporte bien des risques.
Ces risques ne sont peut-être pas aussi énormes et effrayants
que ce que certains de ses opposants veulent nous faire croire,
mais ils existent tout de même.
C'est la troisième surprise qui m'a le plus...
surpris.
Et c'est que beaucoup de patients avec lesquels j'ai pu discuter
et qui se sont tournés vers le cannabis médicinal
ne l'ont pas fait en raison de ses vertus thérapeutiques,
du rapport bénéfice-risque
ou parce qu'ils espéraient un remède miracle,
mais parce qu'il leur donnait du contrôle à exercer sur leur maladie.
Il leur permettait de gérer leur santé
d'une manière productive, efficiente,
efficace et confortable.
Je vais vous expliquer ce que je veux dire.
Robin avait plus de 40 ans quand je l'ai rencontrée.
Mais on lui aurait donné presque 70 ans.
Cela faisait 20 ans qu'elle souffrait de polyarthrite rhumatoïde,
ses mains étaient déformées par la maladie,
sa colonne vertébrale était tordue,
elle se déplaçait en fauteuil roulant.
Elle avait l'air faible et fragile,
et physiquement, elle l'était probablement
mais sur les plans émotif, cognitif et psychologique
c'était une des personnes les plus fortes que j'ai jamais rencontrées.
Quand je me suis assis à côté d'elle
dans un dispensaire de cannabis de Californie du Nord
pour lui demander pourquoi elle s'était tournée vers ce traitement,
quels étaient les bénéfices pour elle,
elle a commencé par me dire
ce que j'avais déjà beaucoup entendu.
Le cannabis apaisait son anxiété,
il apaisait ses douleurs,
et l'analgésie l'aidait à mieux dormir.
Je savais tout ça.
Et puis elle a ajouté quelque chose d'inédit :
que le cannabis lui avait redonné un droit de regard sur sa vie
et sur sa santé.
Elle pouvait en prendre quand elle voulait,
sous n'importe quelle forme,
à la dose et à la fréquence qui lui convenaient.
Et si ça n'allait plus, il n'y avait qu'à modifier.
C'était à elle de décider.
Le plus important, c'était
qu'elle n'avait besoin de la permission de personne.
Pas d'un médecin, ni d'une ordonnance,
ni d'un pharmacien.
C'était entièrement à elle de décider.
C'était son choix à elle seule.
Pour un patient qui souffre d'une maladie chronique,
ce n'est pas un détail.
Quand on souffre d'une maladie chronique grave,
d'une polyarthrite rhumatoïde, d'un lupus, d'un cancer, du diabète,
ou d'une cirrhose,
on perd le contrôle.
Et notez bien que je dis « quand », pas « si ».
Tôt ou tard, nous serons tous confrontés à une grave maladie chronique
qui nous rendra impuissants.
Nous subirons tous un déclin fonctionnel et parfois cognitif,
nous perdrons notre indépendance
et la capacité de faire ce que nous voulons.
Nos corps nous trahiront,
et nous perdrons tôt ou tard le contrôle.
Et cette pensée est effrayante.
Plus qu'effrayante,
elle est terrifiante.
Pour mes patients placés en soins palliatifs,
qui pour la plupart sont confrontés à des maladies qui les tueront,
les raisons d'avoir peur ne manquent pas :
douleurs, nausées, vomissements, constipation, fatigue,
et l'approche de la mort.
Mais ce qui leur fait plus peur que tout,
c'est la possibilité qu'à un moment,
demain ou dans un mois,
ils perdront le contrôle sur leur santé,
leur vie,
leurs soins médicaux,
et qu'ils deviendront dépendants
car cette idée est terrifiante.
Il n'est donc pas vraiment étonnant que des patients comme Robin,
dont je viens de vous parler,
rencontrée dans cette clinique,
se tournent vers le cannabis
pour tenter de retrouver un semblant de contrôle.
Mais comment ?
Comment ces dispensaires de cannabis médicinal,
comme celui où j'ai rencontré Robin,
font-ils pour rendre à Robin et aux autres le contrôle dont ils ont besoin ?
Et que font-ils de plus
que les hôpitaux conventionnels
qui n'étaient pas parvenus à aider Robin ?
Quel est leur secret ?
J'ai décidé d'enquêter.
Je suis allé dans une clinique sordide de Venice Beach en Californie
pour avoir une autorisation
me permettant d'utiliser du cannabis médicinal en tant que patient.
Cette autorisation,
je me la suis procurée illégalement
car je ne réside pas en Californie -
je dois le préciser.
Je précise aussi, pour information,
que je n'ai jamais utilisé cette lettre pour faire d'achat,
et je m'adresse à tous les agents de la DEA -
(Rires)
merci pour votre travail,
continuez comme ça !
(Rires)
Même sans avoir fait d'achat,
cette autorisation m'a permis de me mettre dans la peau d'un patient.
Elle m'a permis de vivre ce que vivent les patients comme Robin
quand ils vont dans un dispensaire de cannabis médicinal.
Et ce que j'ai vécu,
ce que vivent tous les jours
les centaines de milliers de personnes comme Robin,
était vraiment incroyable.
Dès mon arrivée là-bas,
et dès mon arrivée dans tous les dispensaires où j'ai pu me rendre,
j'ai eu l'impression que ce dispensaire
était là pour moi.
Au début, on me demande qui je suis,
quel est mon travail,
ce que j'attends d'une ordonnance de cannabis médicinal,
ou du produit,
quels sont mes objectifs, mes préférences,
mes espoirs,
en quoi je pense ou j'espère que ça pourrait m'aider,
ce dont j'ai peur.
Voilà le genre de questions
qu'on pose toujours aux patients comme Robin.
Voilà le genre de questions qui m'assurent
que mon interlocuteur a vraiment mes intérêts à cœur
et tient à mieux me connaître.
La deuxième chose que j'ai appris dans ces cliniques,
c'est qu'on peut se former partout.
J'ai appris des gens assis derrière le comptoir,
mais aussi des gens assis dans la salle d'attente.
Les gens que j'ai rencontrés étaient plus que disposés -
des gens comme Robin -
à me raconter qui ils étaient et pourquoi ils utilisaient du cannabis médicinal,
ce qui les aidait et comment,
et à me donner des conseils.
Ces salles d'attente sont un vivier d'échanges, de conseils et de soutien.
Et troisièmement, les gens derrière le comptoir.
C'était incroyable de voir comme ces gens
passaient parfois plus d'une heure à m'expliquer les différences
entre plusieurs variétés,
fumer et vaporiser,
ou produit comestible et teinture.
Et tout ça sans effectuer le moindre achat.
Pensez à la dernière fois où vous êtes allés dans un hôpital ou une clinique
et qu'on a passé une heure à vous expliquer ce genre de choses.
Le fait que les patients comme Robin s’adressent à ces cliniques,
s'adressent à ces dispensaires
et reçoivent ce type d'attention personnalisée,
de renseignements et de services,
devrait amener notre système de santé à se remettre en question.
Les gens comme Robin délaissent la médecine conventionnelle,
et se tournent vers ces dispensaires de cannabis
parce que ces dispensaires leur donnent ce dont ils ont besoin.
Cet appel à se remettre en question,
bon nombre de mes collègues ne l'entendent pas
ou ne veulent pas l'entendre.
Quand je parle à mes collègues, surtout médecins,
du cannabis médicinal,
ils disent : « Ah, il faudrait davantage de preuves.
Il faudrait plus de recherche sur les bénéfices et les risques. »
Vous savez quoi ? Ils ont raison.
Tout à fait raison.
Il nous faut bien plus de preuves sur les bénéfices du cannabis médicinal.
Il faut également demander au gouvernement de reclasser le cannabis médicinal
ou de le déréglementer totalement pour pouvoir faire de la recherche.
Il faut aussi faire plus de recherche sur les risques du cannabis médicinal.
Quant à ces risques,
on connait bien les risques liés à l'usage récréatif,
mais on ne sait presque rien de ceux du cannabis médicinal.
Oui, il faut faire plus de recherche
mais s'arrêter là sans dire
qu'il faut changer les choses dès maintenant,
c'est passer à côté du problème.
Le cannabis médicinal n'est pas populaire
parce qu'il serait miraculeux,
ou parce qu'il serait entièrement dénué de risques.
Il est recherché pour le contexte dans lequel il est administré
et utilisé,
et le contrôle qu'il rend aux patients sur leurs vies.
Il faut vraiment que nous nous remettions en question.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que nous pouvons prendre exemple dès aujourd'hui
sur ces dispensaires de cannabis médicinal.
Et nous avons beaucoup à apprendre d'eux.
Ce sont souvent de petites entreprises familiales
gérées par des personnes sans formation médicale.
Il est assez gênant de noter
que bon nombre de ces cliniques réussissent à offrir des services,
un soutien et à répondre aux besoins des patients
là où des systèmes de santé multimilliardaires ont échoué.
Cet embarras est justifié
mais nous pouvons apprendre de nos erreurs.
Nous pouvons apprendre de ces dispensaires
sur au moins trois aspects différents.
D'abord, il faut que nous parvenions à redonner du pouvoir aux patients
par des petites choses qui sont importantes.
Comment interagir avec l'équipe soignante,
quand interagir avec elle,
comment adapter la prise de médicaments.
En tant que médecin,
je fais désormais preuve de créativité et de flexibilité
afin d'aider mes patients à bien prendre leurs médicaments
et gérer leurs symptômes -
en toute sécurité.
Je prescris souvent des opioïdes et des benzodiazépines
qui peuvent être dangereux si l'on en abuse.
Oui, mais attention :
Ils peuvent être dangereux si l'on en abuse
mais aussi potentiellement inefficaces si leur utilisation
ne correspond pas aux besoins des patients.
Cet équilibre judicieux entre flexibilité et sécurité
est extrêmement utile aux patients et à leurs familles.
Voilà le premier point.
Ensuite : la pédagogie.
Nous pouvons
apprendre les secrets de ces dispensaires de cannabis
afin de faire de la pédagogie
sans pour autant qu'un médecin doive être présent,
du moins pas nécessairement.
Nous pouvons mieux connaître les médicaments que nous prescrivons
et leur indication,
les pronostics, l'évolution des maladies,
et surtout,
les patients peuvent apprendre les uns des autres.
Comment reproduire ce qui se passe
dans les salles d'attente de ces dispensaires ?
Comment les patients apprennent-t-ils les uns des autres ?
Et enfin,
mettre les patients au premier plan, comme le font ces dispensaires,
qu'ils sentent que leurs désirs,
leurs besoins
sont la raison d'être
de notre corps de métier.
Les interroger sur leurs espoirs, leurs peurs, leurs buts, leurs préférences.
En soins palliatifs,
je demande à tous mes patients quels sont leurs espoirs et leurs peurs.
Mais voilà.
Les patients ne devraient pas avoir à attendre leur fin de vie,
ou une maladie chronique grave,
ils ne devraient pas avoir à attendre d'être en soins palliatifs
pour qu'on leur demande :
« Quelles sont vos attentes ? » « Et vos peurs ? »
Tout ça devrait être intégré dans l'organisation des soins de santé.
C'est possible,
c'est vraiment possible.
Les dispensaires de cannabis médicinal partout aux Etats-Unis
y parviennent.
Ils y parviennent,
et bien mieux que ne le fait le système de santé conventionnel.
Nous pouvons, nous devons,
suivre leur exemple.
Il suffit de mettre notre orgueil de côté,
et comprendre que ce n'est pas
parce que nous avons des titres,
un statut d'expert,
ou le titre de médecin-chef au sein d'un grand système de santé,
que nous savons toujours comment répondre aux besoins de nos patients.
Il faut ravaler notre fierté.
Il faut aller voir quelques dispensaires de cannabis médicinal.
Il faut comprendre ce qu'ils font.
Il faut comprendre pourquoi autant de patients
désertent notre système de santé
pour s'adresser à ces dispensaires de cannabis médicinal.
Il faut comprendre ce que sont leurs astuces,
leurs outils,
et en tirer des leçons.
Si nous y arrivons,
ce qui est possible mais aussi, selon moi, non négociable,
il est garanti que tous nos patients ne s'en porteront que mieux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)